last year a long time ago we liked about
meditation I think you said it's always
there when you need it if you can
squeeze out
two two minutes of it
you're doing yourself a world of favor
you can think about those times when
you're really stressed to something and
in my career as an actor
and you're on set and you're about to do
a take but you're ever so slightly
distracted all I need is 10 15 seconds
of clarity to get back on point
it's it's just
a wonderful moment of Peace which is a
really cool way of using it as like an
acute tool I have what I call Bubble
time when I'm like on the sofa cuddle up
to my kids like I live in the moment and
pretend it's going to last forever
because you know whether it's two
minutes or three minutes that can be a
long time you can get like this really
you know emotionally rejuvenating moment
which which like to me is your informal
meditation yeah and that's also how I
ended up fixing my sleep my mum just
said stop trying to get to sleep and
just enjoy being in bed I'm comfy I'm
thinking I'm next to Hannah which is
nice so nice that I fall asleep and it's
quite a good way to end your day in that
headspace I remember when you first told
me about that and I've actually used
that myself